>>Jonathan: Welcome to Authors at Google.
It is my great pleasure to introduce my good
friend and award winning author Hallie Ephron
to you all here at Cambridge today.
Hallie and I met when we worked at Digital
more than a few years ago and I've always
been a great fan of her work.
Hallie grew up in Hollywood in a family of
writers.
Her parents were Henry and Phoebe Ephron who
were screenwriters for Fox and wrote screenplays
for movies such as "Desk Set" with Hepburn
and Tracy and "Carousel," the famous musical.
She grew up in a house filled with books and
sisters.
She's three of four sisters, all of whom are
well-known writers.
Nora, Delia and Amy among others.
She went on to become a teacher and writer.
She wrote her first novel "Amnesia" with a
good friend, the neuropsychologist Donald
Davidoff who wrote under the joint pen name
of G.H.
Ephron, and published five novels in the Dr.
Peter Zak series which was really good, I
edited one of the books.
I would recommend them.
She made a big splash writing solo when she
wrote the riveting psychological suspense
thriller "Never Tell A Lie" which was published
in 2009.
Publishers weekly called it "stunning" and
"a deliciously creepy tale of obsession,"
which I agree with.
You kind of do write creepy tales of obsession
don't you for such a regular person.
[laughs]
It was translated into seven languages.
It was a finalist for the Mary Higgins Clark
award of the mystery writers of America.
It was actually adapted into a lifetime movie
"And Baby Will Fall."
Her new novel which she'll be discussing today
presumably is "Come And Find Me" which is
now in its third paperback edition.
Yay.
And it's the story of a recluse who lives
and works online in the cyber security industry
who must brave the real world when her sister
goes missing.
Booklist called it "a suspenseful tale of
high-tech skullduggery that even low-tech
readers will appreciate."
Certainly everybody in this room will do so
also.
She loves to teach and she gives writing workshops.
I keep emptying my bank account trying to
buy everything she's written because in addition
to fiction she's written "Writing and Selling
Your Mystery Novel: How to Knock Them Dead
with Style."
And "The Everything Guide to Writing Your
First Novel."
Plus "The Bibliophile's Devotional" and "1001
Books for Every Mood."
So please join me in welcoming Hallie Ephron.
>>Hallie: Thanks.
[Applause]
Just a reminder, if you don't have a copy
of the book there were five there.
There's a sign-up sheet over there cause we
didn't get quite enough.
Amazon divided it into three shipments and
only one arrived.
And I also put some cards over there so if,
I have a website and it's on here and there's
the contact button.
So if a question occurs to you either about
writing, your writing, my writing, life in
Milton, Massachusetts whatever.
You can e-mail me after, I do read my e-mail
and I'm happy to answer.
Jonathan is one of these people who when you
send your published book which I always do
to.
Or he's actually one of the great friends
who knows that you come to book signings of
authors and buy a book.
Thank you Jonathan.
He will within 10 minutes have found a typo
that eluded you.
Probably on the first page, possibly even
in the title of the book.
[laughs]
But he's really a great editor and I thank
him for helping me along the way.
I worked with Jonathan at Digital and he didn't
say this but it was 30+ years ago.
I know because I was pregnant with my first,
my second child and she's now 33.
So that was back when there was no UI.
There was no user interface.
It was just a black screen with an operating
system prompt.
It said VMS angle bracket as I recall.
And you were expected to go from there.
And we did.
But amazingly we had e-mail.
And we had a dreadful application called "Phone."
Or was it called telephone?
>>Jonathan: Phone.
>>Hallie: Phone.
That everyone hated because it allowed you
to interrupt people in the middle of what
they were doing in their life.
How about that?
Nowadays, it seems like people are on their
phones or on their computers and annoyed when
life interrupts.
I think that's more.
So the world was a little bit upside down
then.
The Internet was still being invented.
And I remember there was an MIT project then
called Project Athena where they were playing
around with something called Boxer.
Does anybody have any idea, well anyway it
was the first tinkering around with the idea
of connecting one piece of information with
another.
Which is really what the web is about.
That's why it's called the web.
Yeah.
Anyway, I had no idea I'd ever write fiction.
And I was tired, getting tired of explaining
to everyone why I was only one in my family
who didn't write.
[laughter]
But it took me about 10 more years.
In the 1990s, actually in the late 80s I started
to write.
And I can still remember, I wrote a book with
a friend of mine whose brother was murdered.
He was shot to death in an insurance office
where they both worked.
They were partners.
And her client had come in angry about a settlement
for a fire.
And shot him, because she was home with her
son who'd hurt his ankle that morning.
And so needless to say, she was guilt ridden,
grief stricken.
And took years to basically come back out
of the house and we spent a long time writing
a book which I never published.
But I do remember sitting at Digital and sending
you know 30 pages to the printer because I
was too cheap and printers were huge back
then.
I mean you know it cost you a fortune to have
a printer in your house.
And running to the printer to grab it before
anybody could see that I was not doing my
work in my cubicle.
I was writing my first novel.
But I did leave, well I don't think they had
been bought by anybody by the time I left.
But you left long before me.
Yeah and so it was in, I got my first book
published in the early 1990s.
And as Jonathan said it was a serious novel
that I wrote with a writing partner.
And it was great for me because my co-author
was a psychiatrist, not a psychiatrist, a
psychologist, a neuropsychologist who still
runs the unit at the McLean, which is the
great psychiatric hospital.
So we wrote stories about a character who
runs a unit at the McLean, but we called it
something else and we put it in the Bermuda
triangle between Belmont and Cambridge.
And they were all stories about things like
memory and delusions and dementia and fear
and shame.
Things that psychologists understand.
And I didn't.
So I was, I was afraid my Don was gonna wanna
write, he was afraid I was gonna make him
write.
So it's really a great partnership and I learned
that I could write and I could write this
kind of stuff.
This kind of slightly creepy, scary but intricately
plotted.
You know a mystery has to be intricately plotted.
And so when we stopped writing together I
was afraid I wasn't ever gonna to have an
idea for a book.
Because all the ideas, many of them had really
been generated by Don.
I had done all the writing but I hadn't really
come up with the premises.
Finally one day I found an idea at a yard
sale.
I love yard sales.
I went to a yard sale at a house near mine.
My daughter had played at this house, it's
a big, old, Victorian beautiful on the outside,
horrible on the inside.
And they were taken down walls and making
it into a great house.
And so I was chatting up the woman in the
driveway.
And I said, you know did you change the ceiling
in the kitchen.
I mean I knew, I recognize the toilet they
were throwing away.
I really knew that house.
So I, she said, finally, "Would I like to
go inside and look around?"
I said "Oh I'd like to, yes very much."
She said well go ahead there's no one inside
just help yourself you know your way.
So I went, there's something very creepy about
going into someone else's empty house.
I went and I'm looking around, I go upstairs.
Finally on the second floor the mystery writer
in me kicked in and I thought what if a woman
goes to a yard sale, somehow she talks her
way into the house.
She goes inside and she never comes out.
And I went home, very quickly.
[laughter]
I didn't want to stay in that house any longer.
And I started to write.
I didn't know who the woman was who came to
the yard sale, but I knew she was nine months
pregnant.
I didn't know what the connection was between
her and the woman throwing the yard sale but
I knew that the woman throwing the yard sale
was also nine months pregnant.
And I proceeded to write this book completely
ignoring all the rules that I have set forth
in my "Writing and Selling Your Mystery Novel:
How to Knock Them Dead with Style."
Because I just wanted to see who these characters
were and where it took me.
As a result the writing process was very ugly.
It took about two years whereas a serious
novel usually took me a year.
But the result was something quite different
than anything I had written before.
I got a much better contract.
I got a much better agent.
I saw, I finally stopped doing all the freelance
work that I had been doing up to that time
in order to support my writing habit.
And I started to really feel like a writer.
So that book was a really great experience.
It was sold to lifetime movie network and
then of course I was paranoid that I was never
gonna come up with an idea for my next novel.
As I am now having just turned in my third
novel, I don't know what I'm gonna write next.
The trough between books is very difficult
place to be.
But, "Come And Find Me."
You know ideas come from the weirdest places,
and this one I think it started, I blog with
a bunch of other mystery writers on a blog
called Jungle Red Writers.
And every once in a while we offer a book,
a free book.
Fairly often actually.
And when that happens, we get this deluge
of commenters that we know could care less
about Jungle Red Writers.
But it turns out that there are, but they're
real.
It's not a bot or anything.
And they're different because we actually
try to contact them and see if we're just
getting the same e-mail from the same person
over and over.
We're not.
And it turns out there are these websites
that tell people about contests.
And then people who go every day, and then
they entered every contest.
And that's what they do.
And at the same time I had a neighbor who
never left her house.
But she always got these package deliveries.
And I thought, well what if you know the neighbor
is one of these.
Cause if you enter enough contests, you win
a fair number of them.
So these packages just kept arriving.
And you know, her only contact with the world
seemed to be the UPS man.
So I started thinking about it, and I started
coming up with the story of a woman.
Who, and this is Diana in "Come And Find Me,"
who is at home.
And she's at home because she's afraid to
leave the house.
But she runs, and this was where I had to
figure out how could you, was there a way
that you could run a computer security business
from your house and never leave it?
And could you actually live that way?
And I started thinking about the Internet
and how it connects people.
But also allows people to isolate themselves
physically.
And also, allows people to get spoofed.
You don't really know that an e-mail is coming
from the person that it says it's coming from.
When I look at my pinhole camera in the frame
of my MacBook, I often wonder if someone's
looking back at me.
So it's also a place that can generate a fair
amount of paranoia and you just really don't
want to think about it too much, or you become
a little bit crazy.
So I started to research, I've been a long
time out of the computer business.
And never been a gamer.
You know really, the mouse and the just completely
slays me.
I don't really know what I'm doing with the
mouse buttons.
So I knew I needed to do some research.
So I got in touch with this guy named Jeff
Bardin.
Has anybody heard of him?
He's a security expert, and I wanted to find
out from him first of all what were the greatest
threats on the Internet?
I wanted there to be something at the core
of this novel that was not a terrorism and
not robbing a bank.
I have no interest in either of those things.
I wanted something that would be personally
scary.
High-stakes, but at a personal level.
And so I met with him and he told me.
You know I said can somebody live in their
house and have a business.
And he told me about Second Life.
I'm sure most you know about Second Life.
Well in my book, it's called Otherworld cause
I didn't want to get sued.
And he was telling me you know about the porn.
About the cyber terrorism that you know people
are actually training terrorists in Second
Life.
As well as, just normal people wandering around
and you know, going from island to island
and buying things in Second Life and finding
like-minded people.
And so it had this, it has the positive and
the negative side that I wanted, cause that's
what I see in computers is both a very positive
and a very scary side.
So I of course figured, well, nothing with
computers scares me.
I've been online for years and years and years
and it's just not a scary thing.
So I went to SecondLife.com and created an
avatar and that was fun.
It was like my Betsy McCall doll, you know
getting her dressed and figuring out not so
easy for me how to make her move forward and
not bump into furniture.
And then flying which is very cool cause you
kind of felt like, kind of felt like Harry
Potter on the back of Buckbeak, cause its
first person you know you're watching and
flying over and it was very cool.
And then I fell in the ocean.
And I couldn't get her out, I mean I just
could not figure out how to get the character.
And I was like breathless.
You know gasping.
And I thought, you know you really do connect
with your avatar.
And I also, I was three hours into this odyssey
and realizing that there was not enough time
in the world for me to get as good as I needed
to get to really learn about Second Life.
So back up and I started to call.
You know I put out something on Facebook to
all the people that I had worked with you
know from HP.
I've listed a startup, I was in all kinds
of computer companies.
Somebody must know somebody who plays in Second
Life and works in Second Life.
I wanted both experiences.
So I connected with someone at Raytheon who
conducts training.
She creates training events for them in Second
Life.
And so I went and sat next to her and rode
shotgun and watched her and took copious notes
on how you do all the things that she did.
And while she was showing me a place where
they were having training, this virtual metal
cylinder dropped over her avatar.
And she explained to me that there were griefers,
these were people who had managed to get into
this place cause there wasn't enough security.
And again, it was just so creepy, you know
that this could happen.
And she was telling me that there was a lot
of porn in Second Life.
My second guides to Otherworld were a couple
who lived up in one of the northern suburbs
in the house that, I gotta put this house
in this book one day.
It was shag carpeting and cigarette smoke.
And coffee that smelled like they never started
over with the coffee.
And the house; very nice people.
But I was, sneezing and gasping for breath
within 2 minutes.
A lot of dogs too.
A lot of dogs and cats.
But they kind of just hang out in Second Life.
And so again you know I sat next to the husband
in this case and he showed me how he could
see which of his friends were online and how
to go where they were and the coordinates.
Just tried to get enough information that
I could make myself feel credible without
really learning Second Life which I really
did not.
I'm not, as I said it really did not interest
me to really experience it.
So I, so that was my adventure on Second Life.
And you know I was able to see where it could
be both scary and fun.
And also helpful.
As I was talking to Jeff Bartin I mean I wanted
some way that there would be a danger here
as well.
One of the things that he started telling
me about was just how everything is on the
network and therefore vulnerable in its way.
So just take a hospital for instance.
The security cameras are networked.
The machines that monitor your vital signs
are networked.
All your data that your doctor has about you
is potentially on the network.
The machine that administers morphine when
you need a hit is.
DNA profiles.
And on and on it goes.
And you know you can start to get paranoid
and start to, what I did was start to spin
a what if there were a hacker who could use
those vulnerabilities to hold hospitals and
insurance companies for ransom.
And I mean that's really, the other person
that I did a lot of research with, not a lot,
I spent a couple hours with him is a former
hacker who now works for computer companies.
And he was telling me how in the early days
of hacking, it was kind of cowboys.
People were doing it for fun.
And to show that they could.
And to one up each other.
It was a very kind of male and juvenile in
its way.
You know kind of showing off.
And that now things have changed quite a bit.
That it's really much more a business.
And people make a lot of money.
And there's a lot of dollars at stake.
So, I mean I wasn't really interested in the
hacker in the Ukraine who's getting into computers
and getting people's credit card.
To me that's got no juice as a mystery story.
But I was interested in the potential of getting
in and getting DNA profiles and what you could
do with that.
Getting in and monitoring people in the hospital
when they didn't know they were being monitored.
That seemed like much more of a personal violation.
And so that's kind of what leads into the
subplot.
I also got really interested in the idea of
an avatar.
That this is a person that you create online.
Your personality but in a way in a Halloween
costume.
You know you could be whoever you wanted to
be.
A third apparently of the avatars in Second
Life that are female are really you know controlled
and created by men.
So you have no idea.
So it's a great opportunity to try on different
personas, to try to be someone you're not,
to fool people or take advantage of them.
And my feeling was that for my character who
was stuck in a house her avatar would be a
way for her to get out.
For her to be person she used to be but online.
Having said that, and all that computer stuff,
the other thing that always drives me, the
creepy part is, I come from a movie family,
I always think very cinematically about the
books that I'm writing as if the narrator
is a camera in one of the characters heads.
And I always, always am going for what I call
the light bulb in the milk moment.
If you've ever seen Alfred Hitchcock, and
Alfred Hitchcock is my idol, I mean if I could
write books the way, that make you feel the
Way, Alfred Hitchcock does when you're at
the end of the second act moving into the
third act and winding up.
I always remember the movie "Suspicion."
And "Suspicion", some you will know.
Joan Fontaine is the wife, she's upstairs,
an invalid in bed, awash in satin sheets.
And she's sure that her husband is trying
to kill her.
Her husband, Cary Grant is climbing the stairs
at that moment carrying a silver tray and
on the tray is glass of milk.
And Hitchcock does you know the famous back
and forth between them.
You know we hear her, we see him, little closer
to her, a little closer to him, until we come
right in on the milk.
And he never has to say anything because we
know there's got to be poison in that milk.
And the milk seems to glow.
And of course the trick was Hitchcock put
a light bulb in the milk.
I mean, he was not subtle.
[laughter]
But you don't realize that when you're watching
it.
And for me always when I'm writing, I'm reaching
for that kind of a moment.
What I love about it is, milk is nourishing.
Warm milk is what puts you to sleep, relaxes
you.
It's this very nourishing thing, and yet he
twists it and makes it scary.
And so in my books I'm always going for that
moment.
In "Come And Find Me," Diana is home.
She's got her house surrounded with surveillance
cameras and she can look at them anytime she
wants.
And she checks in every once in a while.
And there on her front fence is a cardinal
sitting.
A little while later she checks, the cardinal
is back.
The third time she checks and the cardinal
is in the same place.
That's a light bulb in the milk moment.
Because she realizes she's not seeing what's
outside.
Someone has replaced her video feed with a
continuous loop.
And that's, she's not really, something else
is going on out there and she can't see.
So inside becomes scarier than outside.
And she finally leaves the house.
So that's just a little insight into where
I, into where I'm thinking when I, cause I
do set them in the suburbs.
I do set them in places that should be not
scary places.
But I'm always trying to make them scary.
I thought I would read just a little bit from
the book.
This isn't anything about computers.
One of the other things I wanted to write
about with this book was the relationship
between sisters.
I have a lot of them.
And so what drives Diana out of the house
is that her sister is missing.
And this is a scene where she's talking to
her mother.
She's managed to leave the house.
She knows something is wrong.
And she knows that her sister should've called
her mother, so she calls her mother.
"What's wrong?" her mother said the minute
she heard Diana's voice on the phone.
"Why should there be something wrong?"
"Because you never call me, I call you.
Your sister calls me, that's the way things
work in this family."
"So has she?"
"Why is it always a contest?"
Diana took a breath, "Let's start over.
Hi Ma, how are you."
For the last five years her mother had lived
in Jensen Beach Florida in a condo surrounded
by golf courses.
"Men golfed" she explained to Diana, forever
hopeful that she'd find a better partner than
Diana's father who disappeared from their
lives long before he'd taken off with the
woman who Diana and Ashley referred to as
Tiffany, because that was her favorite place
to shop.
She had not long after been replaced by Tiffany
2.
"Sorry, do I sound cranky?" her mother said.
"I can't complain, a few creaky joints.
I've always thought that was a figure of speech.
But it turns out they do creak and click.
It's unnerving.
I mean I make a fist and the knuckles make
a sound.
And my back, my doctor tells me to walk more,
says it's normal for my age.
Do you think he's just telling me that because
there's nothing for it?
Like I said, I can't complain."
Her mother snorted a laugh, "Guess I can.
Hah, in fact I'm really good at complaining.
But actually, on the whole and considering
everything I'm good.
Hey, I beat the big C. What else can he throw
at me?
Carpe diem, that's what I say.
Carpe diem every single goddamn day.
How about you sweetie pie?"
Her mother actually paused.
Diana waited until she was certain that her
mother wasn't going to answer the question
herself.
"I'm good."
"Good, just good?
That's nice I guess.
You getting out of the"
"Some."
"Good.
I'm glad you're getting out.
And if you're not taking a vitamin D supplement,
you should be.
You don't want osteoporosis to get you when
you're my age."
There was a moment of silence.
"You know, all I want is for you to be happy.
Your sister tells me"
"So did she call?"
"Last week.
She was supposed to call this morning, Monday
morning she always calls."
Monday morning.
Ashley usually answered her messages and showed
up at work too.
"Has something happened to your Sister?" her
mother asked.
"Because all weekend I felt something was
off.
I thought it was me.
Then today she doesn't call and you do.
Is something up?"
"Nothing's up.
I haven't actually talked to her either."
"Since?"
"Friday."
"Ah, did you check her apartment?"
"She's not answering her phone."
"Because she's not there, or"
The silence that followed felt laden with
the accusation and an image of Ashley lying
on her kitchen floor paralyzed and unable
to reach for the phone.
Her mother went on.
"I'm sure she'll turn up hon, she always does.
Try not to worry about it too much."
Two years ago Diana would've been the one
trying to reassure her mother.
"Good advice."
"I'm full of good advice, don't you know that?"
"Thanks mom, I'll call.
I'll tell her to call.
Bye."
"Shhh." her mother cut her off.
From the day she'd been diagnosed with cancer
Diana's mother had insisted that they never
end a conversation with any version of goodbye.
"Sorry.
I meant talk to you soon", Diana said.
"Knock wood."
So that's the character who is about to leave
her house.
So I thought I would take questions at this
point.
Anybody working on a book?
Anybody interested in the writing process?
The book?
You name it.
Yes.
>>Male #1: Do you outline?
>>Hallie: Do I outline?
I do.
I never follow it, but I do outline.
[laughter]
I have people say, people often ask you know
do you know the ending before the beginning.
And I always say, "I think I do but I'm usually
wrong."
But that's the thing about an outline.
You know it's like any work process.
You know you have enough colleagues that some
people never bother to make lists.
Other people are compulsive list makers, even
if they never read them.
So I do make an outline because I feel like
it gives me training wheels.
And then I can start writing.
And then I almost immediately go off.
Because characters when you put them on the
page are never quite the way that you thought
they would be.
Which is a good thing.
Because I feel like if I can surprise myself,
I can surprise the reader and that's a great
thing to be able to do in a mystery, is to
create a character that people think is going
to go this way and then goes that way.
And then, well that's interesting.
Why did they do that?
So as a writer I'm constantly having to change
the outline.
I change the outline as I go.
So as I write, I rewrite the outline.
And by the time I'm done I have an outline
that does reflect my book.
And I use it.
It's a very useful thing.
But the other thing that happens as your character
goes off the rails you have to change the
back story.
Back story is the stuff that the writer knows
about the character but the reader doesn't.
So when I put a character on a page, I know
all kinds of things about her or him that
you don't know.
I know where she grew up, I know if she went
to college.
I know if she hates her father.
I know she smokes.
I know what kind of car she drives probably.
I know what kind of car she'd never drive.
And so all that stuff and why, is in my head.
Sometimes I'll actually write it in a character
bible they call it.
Just a bunch of stray notes about a character.
But as a character surprises me, I have to
go back and change my assumptions about who
that character is, to change the back story.
So it's kind of a shifting back and shifting
forward always.
This, I just turned in a new book called,
what is it called?
It's called, "There Was an Old Woman."
And I got to page 125.
And I had an outline for the whole book.
But I couldn't write another page.
I just got stuck, I was bored.
And I went back, I went forward.
I did everything I could think of.
Everything everyone's ever told me about writer's
block I tried.
And finally I just decided to throw away the
first 125 pages.
Of course I didn't throw it away, I just put
it in the out file which I start the minute
I start a book.
And I realized I had started the book in the
wrong place.
So I started over.
And wrote my way up to where I had been and
was able to use some of what I had and then
move forward.
But it was, I think you just have to be fearless
as a writer.
And though you have an outline, don't think
that you can follow it.
I mean I think it's like many project plans.
I mean every once in a while you'll hit a
bump in the road that you weren't expecting
and you have to change all your assumptions
and then change your milestones on where you're
going, it's kind of a similar thing.
Other questions?
Yeah.
>>Male #2: You mentioned the Jungle Red Writers..
>>Hallie: Yep.
>>Male #2: Do you get together as a group
and critique each other's work in the blog?
>>Hallie: No but that's a good question.
He asked if the people that I blog with, I
blog with some really wonderful mystery writers.
Deborah Crombie, Rhys Bowen, Julia Spencer
Fleming, Hank Phillippi Ryan.
And I do ask Hank to read my work cause she's
a good friend.
But for the most part, I don't ask anyone
to read my work until I'm done.
And that's because I don't, I'm too ready
to slash and burn.
And I, the slightest, I mean I don't own my
words at all.
I'm very easy with criticism, but a little
over easy.
Because sometimes you throw away what you've
got before you realize what you wanted to
say.
So I feel like I at least have to get those
first 300 pages out.
And know where I'm going before I give it
to somebody to critique.
Then I'll be happy to change anything, but
at least I know what I meant to say.
Because otherwise you end up writing someone
else's book.
And that's not a good thing.
You don't even know what you wanted to say
in the first place.
So I do have people read it, and I have a
wonderful literary agent who always after
I've made what I think is the best book I
can, she reads it and I usually get a lot
of notes they call it, from her and I revise
it and then I send it to my editor.
Fortunately I'm under contract right now,
so I have an editor and a deadline which is
a wonderful thing.
And I'm just working my way through my notes
now on the new manuscript.
And it's quite, it's quite a bit more than
I thought I was gonna get I must say.
But it's always getting better.
But at least I knew what I wanted say in the
first place.
You know, you don't even know what your themes
are, I never know what my themes are in my
book until I'm done writing.
And then I look and I say, I mean, "Never
Tell a Lie" was about what it's like to be
completely at that period of vulnerability
when you have your first child and you've
been out in the working world the whole time.
It's also about the mess that your high school
experience permanently leaves in your head.
And "Come and Find Me" is about trust.
It's about knowing who you can trust and about
how you deal with people who betray you.
Trust and betrayal.
And you know, I just tell the stories and
then realize later what I'm writing about.
I mean I just don't, you don't want to shortcut
that process.
Did you have a question?
Yeah.
>>Male #3: There are a lot of books that you
probably would like to be reading.
How do you find the time?
Do you read them all?
Do you read the newest?
Do you read the classics?
I mean what do you do for, how do you get
the time?
>>Hallie: Yeah, one of the things.
One of the things I do as a sideline is I
review crime fiction for the Boston Globe.
I have a column that runs every other month
in the globe.
And so I'm always chipping away at, it's only
three books every other month, that is not
a lot of books.
But I get about 60 books every two weeks delivered
to my door.
So I have to sort through them and make a
short pile of the ones I'm interested in reading.
And I start a lot of books that I don't finish.
I hate to review a book I don't like because
I hate to read a book I don't like.
What is more painful than reading a book you
don't like?
So I would rather leave enough time to put
it aside.
>>Female #1: Why bother?
>>Hallie: Exactly.
Exactly.
And then also there so little ink for authors
right now.
I mean there's so few newspapers being printed,
there's so few real book reviews.
Almost none.
It's such a fraction of what it used to be.
So I really don't want to be putting negative
reviews out when I could be telling people
about books to read, not books not to read.
What is the point?
So having said that, I start a lot of books
but I also have my pile of, I mean I just
finished all the "Hunger Games."
[laughter]
Which I loved, I have to say, but I'm a big
Harry Potter fan too you know, I love the
Harry Potter fans.
All of the books, I read them all.
I just read the book, one of the books that
was nominated for the Edgar this year which
I loved.
It's called "The Devotion of Suspect X."
Has anyone read that?
Oh it's brilliant.
It's about a, it's about a mathematician.
It's about a woman who killed; you know in
the first scene a woman kills her ex-husband.
And her neighbor is going to work with her
to hide, you know, to figure out how she's
gonna get away with it.
He was awful in abusive and the guy is a kind
of Aspergersy mathematician.
And his nemesis is a physicist that he went
to university with.
And there's all, it's just, it's diabolical.
And it's got a plot twist I did not see coming.
It's got a great plot twist.
So I've also got my stack of books you know
that I want to read.
I want to read Gilead.
I got a lot of books, all kinds of books that
I just don't get to.
Yes.
>>Male #4: The description you have of you
know how people's lives are so networked and
you know we're so vulnerable with all this
information.
It reminded me of "The Net" you know the Sandra
Bullock movie.
>>Hallie: Yeah.
>>Male #4: I was wondering where that fits
in and now it's been what, 17 years since
it came out?
>>Hallie: That's true.
I had forgotten about that movie.
Yeah.
>>Male #4: [Inaudible] things may have changed
or how we've accepted things that.
>>Hallie: I think we've accepted a lot of
things.
One of the things that is key in this book
is a flash mob.
And of course, when the net was written, flash
mobs hadn't yet been invented.
But I think there's a playfulness about the
Internet that was not.
Because it's just a part of your life.
I mean it's just there.
I think it was much newer then.
And I think, but I love the playfulness of
it.
I love Facebook, I love being able to connect
to people I don't know.
I like trying to assess out which people are,
are not real.
[Laughs]
I don't know, I guess, I think it's possible
to take it a lot less seriously than.
But I do love those.
Has anybody seen the new "Sherlock Holmes"?
Yeah.
On public television, there's a new "Sherlock
Holmes" with Cumberbatch, great name.
It's the name of the.
But what's cool about it is it's set in the
present and it's full of computery things.
You know they're like little butterflies that
pop up every once in a while.
And it's extremely cool that, and weird because
I always think of Sherlock Holmes as the perfect
vehicle for steam punk.
Which in its way is sort of a twisted version,
cause it's set in the old-time me.
But this is taking the same idea but setting
it absolutely in modern day.
I think it's very cool.
Anyway, I think it's become more playful.
I think were less afraid.
I think we know, I think we've just stop worrying.
Because how can you do otherwise?
I mean, you know.
I mean you don't get those e-mails every other
day.
Oh my God, there's a virus.
And, all that stuff has really settled down.
And I think people have gotten smarter about
protecting, I hope, our computers.
>>Female #2: Overloaded and turned it off.
>>Hallie: Yeah I think, I think you're right.
I think you're right.
Yes.
>>Male #5: So you wrote a book on how to write
a mystery novel.
>>Hallie: I did yeah.
>>Male #5: And you decided that wasn't right
thing to do?
>>Hallie: Oh no no.
It's just that that process that I talked
about in that book didn't work for the book
I was writing.
>>Male #5: So are you going to rewrite the
book?
>>Hallie: No, because it's chaos.
You cannot recommend chaos to people.
[laughter]
I mean, what I say in "Writing and Selling
Your Mystery Novel" is that writing a novel
is a very personal process.
Everyone will do it differently because we're,
you have to take advantage of your strengths
and we all have different strengths.
And so, on the other hand, it doesn't hurt
to hear how other people do it and try some
of those techniques that they have and see
if they work for you.
So I kinda hedged my bets when I wrote it.
And I still believe that.
And I also think that different books write
differently.
This book for instance, "There Was an Old
Woman," I knew the ending.
It's the first thing I knew.
I absolutely knew the ending, never gonna
change.
That's the ending.
There's a huge plot twist at the end and I
had it from the beginning.
In "Come and Find Me" there's a final scene
where she confronts the person who's been
jerking her around.
And I knew she was going to one up him.
She was gonna, she was gonna get him.
But I didn't know how.
And so, I mean I just, I was afraid of writing
up to that point cause I was gonna have figure
it out.
And I did.
So it's just, it's very different everybody
right.
But I do think, I mean I remember when I was
first starting, the first writing conference
I ever went to.
And they're great to go to if you're a writer
cause you hear all kinds, you hear every writer
tell their process and it's so different.
So you just give up of there being one way.
But I remember there was the keynote speaker
was some very well published writer.
You know Pulitzer Prize winner, blah blah
blah.
And she said, somebody asked her, "What's
your writing process?"
And she said, in all seriousness, "It's magic."
And you know, I thought that's like saying
"I can do it and you can't."
You know?
It's the ultimate auteur.
And it really turned me off, that was before
I wrote my book.
I thought that's bullshit.
There's a million ways to write a book.
So tell us what yours is and we'll find out
what some.
And then you put it together for yourself.
It's just a process to an end.
Yes.
>>Male #6: It sounds little bit like Nash,
you know John Nash when he went crazy right?
It's like how come you didn't know that becoming
the Emperor of Antarctica was weird.
He said, "Well it came to me the same way
the mathematical ideas came to me."
>>Hallie: Yeah, yeah.
>>Male #6: Sorta the same way.
>>Hallie: Well see that's the problem with,
the kind of books that I write really do have
a form.
And that's one of the things that I write
about in that writing book is what is, what
do people expect when they pick up a book
that's been shelved with the mystery books.
You know, there's a certain expectation.
And that's not to say you have to write a
book that conforms to those expectations but
readers will not be happy if they pulled it
off the mystery shelf and it doesn't feel
like a mystery.
So what I was writing about a lot was the
structure of a mystery.
It always always opens with a scene that throws
a character off-balance.
Just like a movie actually.
Movies always open with those, start noticing.
I mean they always open with, it doesn't have
to be a dead body, it can be a guy parking
his Porsche at the apartment building, coming
up the stairs walking down the hall.
The door to his apartment is ajar.
He pushes it open all the furniture is gone.
And there's a red stiletto heel in the middle
of the bare floor.
That's a great opening.
I mean I haven't written that one yet.
[laughter]
But I will one day.
That's a short story.
So you know, it's a what's going on here moment.
And that's how you always want to always start
a book it's with that.
Then you move on.
You start the first act.
And there's a twist, and there's a second
act and there's a twist.
Third act, there's a confrontation, there's
a mop up.
So there's this rough structure that like.
If you, you hear people talk about screenplays,
they are much worse.
Because in a mystery novel, I have 300 pages
to play with.
A screenplay is like 100 and, it's not even
100 I think.
So it's, but it's a very demanding structure
which is partly why I like to write them.
I always feel like, it's like I'm in a playground
and there's only certain equipment.
So I can use all my imagination, but I've
still got just a slide and a jungle.
And you know it's like certain things that
I can play with.
And it's kind of reassuring.
>>Female #3: So along with the whole class
structure, there's also this introducing your
character, filling out the character.
You know I've read some books where it's very
awkward and forced feeling.
Like okay now we take a break to give you
a little monologue about this character.
>>Hallie: Published books?
>>Female #3: Yeah.
>>Hallie: Oh God.
>>Female #3: You know and then there's some
books where you're reading them and really
the character naturally fills out and you
learn things that you know doesn't feel stilted
or.
>>Hallie: One of the chapters in writing and
selling your mystery novel talks about avoiding
the back story dump.
>>Female #3: Yeah.
>>Hallie: And that's exactly what you're talking
about.
And I'm surprised we find it in out, actually
it's in the girl with the Dragon tattoo.
The whole first 50 pages for me could of gone
right in the you know.
Until Lizbeth Salander shows up on the, were
not really engaged with what's his name.
And we have all, you see I don't remember
his is name.
What is his name?
>>Audience: Mikael Blomkvist.
>>Hallie: Thank you, Blomkvist.
[laughter]
Her I remember, she's the reason people read
that book.
But that's a typical mistake that you see
in new writers is they feel like they have.
Remember I said there's all this stuff that
you know about the character that the reader
doesn't know.
The challenge is to keep it yourself.
And let the characters show by what they wear,
what they eat, what they do, what they say.
Let the reader put together the back story
through these details that you drop.
And occasionally a bit of internal dialogue
and revelation through dialogue.
But, you're right, that's deadly.
And as I say, it's one of the biggest problems
for a new writer.
Is figuring out how to introduce the character
without weighing down the front of the story.
The reason it doesn't work is because readers
don't care about the character yet.
They don't care about the situation.
And so you have to get the story moving.On
the other hand, the writers say "well but
they don't know this and they don't know that."
Well yeah, you have been led to.
Yeah.
>>Male #7: So what's your discipline?
Do you start 9-to-5 on Monday , I mean do
you work 9-to-5 on Monday through Friday or
how does that.
>>Hallie: I write every day that I can.
Unless I, I've got, I have grown daughters
and when they're home all bets are off.
I want to be wherever they are when they are
within striking distance.
But I get up every morning.
I start around seven at the computer.
And I work usually until about 10:30.
And then I'll take a walk or go to the fitness
center.
Have lunch.
Take a nap.
I need a nap.
And then I come back to the computer around
three till about six.
So I have a very set routine.
I like to write first draft in the morning.
I like to revise my brain isn't.
You've gotta be really clearheaded in the
morning.
And I have to say one of the most fruitful
times for me plotting, is lying in bed before
I get up.
You know that, they call it, it's that almost
dream state that you're in.
>>Male #8: Hypnagogic is one word.
>>Hallie: That it, hypnagogic, or have the
hypnopompic, they're the other ends of the
day.
And it's a very fruitful time for imagination.
And so I will often walk through my plot wherever
I am at that point.
And try to think about what could happen next
that I wasn't thinking was going to happen
next.
And so I, I like that.
And then I have to get down to the computer
or I will forget.
[laughs]
What I was thinking before I got there.
Other questions?
Yes.
>>Female #4: It seems to me that with this
latest book, you've taken people who like
to have colorful excitement in their inner
lives while they're reading and you've given
them a heroine who is living in this little
world.
Can you see that telescoping into a place
where it's really hard to get out without
someone coming to find you?
>>Hallie: Yeah.
Well, I mean that was one of the challenges
of the book.
I mean here's a character who lives in a little
house.
And she's closed herself off to the outside
world.
I had to get her out.
Because it's boring.
You know, it's claustrophobic.
I don't want to write a book that stays there.
Did anybody read "Room?"
Nobody read it?
Oh you people have to read more.
"Room" is a fabulous book.
It was last year's, or maybe the year before.
It's the story, it opens, its told from the,
sorry, from the point of view of a five-year-old.
Which is a tour de force in and of itself.
And gradually we come to realize that he is
with his mother in what amounts to an oversized
packing crate.
They are imprisoned there.
There's a bed.
They have a, you know it's like what happened
to Elizabeth Smart you know who was.
Only it's from the point of view of the five-year-old.
And when I started reading that book I thought
oh my God, she's gonna stay, how long are
we gonna be in this packing crate.
Because, you just can't sustain a story that
long in, yeah.
So fortunately, they do get out.
[laughs]
But she was in there longer than I would've,
longer than I would've imagined.
So no I don't want to write.
I like to write characters that are resilient
because I think characters that are too whiny
and stay where they are.
They're not interesting.
You know I want a character who.
And that's why I keep getting nominated for
the Mary Higgins Clark award.
I've never read a Mary Higgins Clark novel
I must tell you.
But I think what she writes about are women
who are kind of beset upon and then they save
themselves.
I think, and so I, that's what I like to write
as somebody who is not gonna whine, but she's
gonna sock somebody.
Eventually.
[Laughs]
>>Female #4: It sounds like you had to, she
was in there so tightly that you had to pushing
her out of the house cause it was too scary
to stay.
And something pulling her out.
>>Hallie: She had to be pushed and pulled.
That inside of the house had to be scarier
than the outside and she had to go out and
save her sister.
So she, yeah that's right she had to be pushed
and pulled.
Yeah, the pulling didn't just do it cause
she would've just called the police.
One of the biggest problems in writing a mystery
novel, why doesn't she just call the police.
[laughter]
Well thank you very much, be sure to sign
up for a book, I hope you'll want one if you
didn't get one.
>>Jonathan: We're gonna go over to Chavin
for lunch, anybody that would like to join
us you're more than welcome.
>>Hallie: Yay.
Yeah.
And I'm serious about if you have questions.
The follow-up, just e-mail me.
I'm happy to help.
Happy to reply.
Thank you.
[applause]